[Music]
of all the things civilization beyond
Earth's first expansion accomplishes the
greatest is this it swords through
centuries of war politics and civic
progress to reveal the personality
hidden beneath it all developer fair
axis games has a reputation for making
bold expansions and rising tide is no
exception
it doesn't just add content to the
sci-fi strategy game it reimagined
certain systems altogether and brings
real characters into the formula as in
beyond earth proper rising tide puts you
in the throne or council chamber
depending on the leader you choose to be
as you guide your civilization to
victory on alien planets in the distant
future although there are still five
paths to victory both peaceful and
otherwise the methods of reaching them
have changed because rising tide lets
you colonize the seas so while naval
combat and exploration are still key
factors in any smart ruler strategy its
expansion brings cities complete with
all their commerce resources and
hardworking people into the waves
and in rising tide ocean cities can move
it takes a few turns depending on the
city's production rating but these
floating metropolis can travel across
water one hexagonal tile at a time in
any direction you choose the result is a
brilliant new dichotomy between your
thinking on land and your approach at
sea and because citizens can still only
work tiles within three spaces of the
nearest city building a seafaring
province means dealing with loss
short-term games are far more valuable
at sea where resources are ephemeral and
cities might abandon farms generators
and academies in an instant rising tide
also introduces a new diplomacy system
you strike international deals manage
alliances and change your leaders
personality traits by spending
diplomatic capital other leaders will in
turn come to fear or respect you build
up a big enough army and they'll accept
your deals out of off but manage your
sieve with a wise leaders acumen and
surrounding dignitaries will join out of
admiration this diplomacy system races
to complaints I had with beyond earth
proper first it adds dynamism to the
mid-game turns which used to be boring
if you weren't always expanding but this
feature does something more it injects
personality into beyond earth the
leaders develop unique idiosyncrasies
growing into
angry tyrants or peaceful visionaries
and after a while I developed opinions
about each one of them however it's
often unclear why a ruler approves or
disapproves of your actions this is
important because their thoughts affect
their standing toward you at one point
Priscilla's leaders scoffed at my
production rates only to compliment them
once I raised them a mere two points
higher rising tide didn't offer a
quantitative explanation for why this
was the case there can also be an
overload of information farther into
games when every ruler sounds off on
every move I make but these characters
still feel genuine this isn't the level
of characterization you'll find in a
role-playing game or story driven
experience but these personalities did
influence my decisions rising tide
brings new hybrid affinity units old
world artifacts and four new factions to
beyond Earth you can also find resource
pods and alien ruins filled with useful
materials across the map but these
welcome additions pale in comparison to
the systemic changes fear access has
made there are several bothersome issues
with a new diplomacy approach and some
of these mechanics still seem too
arbitrary to call excellent but rising
tide encourages new ways of thinking and
lends new character to a game and dire
need of it and of course that old
civilization mantra still echoes just
like it used to one more turn
[Music]
you